مرحبا بك محمد وبمشاهدينا اهلا بكم الى
ميونخ هنا في المانيا هنا في ميونخ
الاجواء بارده ولكن
القمه الساخنه بملفاتها المشتعله هذا مطبخ
العالم للسياسات الامنيه هنا تطبخ السياسه
الامنيه في العالم
وهذه السنه تعقد هذه القمه قمه ميونخ بدون
روسيا بعد سنه من غزوها لي اوكرانيا ويحضر
هذه القمه 150 مسؤولا بين مسؤولين ورؤساء
ووزراء 30 رئيس دوله موجود في هذه القمه
وايضا اكثر او نحو 100 وزير في هذه القمه
قمه ميولخ الامنيه على مدار ثلاثه ايام
يبحثون ملفات اولها الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه عفوا على اوكرانيا بعد مرور سنه
كما ذكرنا على الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
ومواضيع او امدادات الطاقه واي ضا
العلاقات الامريكيه الروسيه
يسعدنا في هذه النافذه ان نستضيف معنا هنا
رئيس لاجيا الموجود في هذه القمه اهلا
وسهلا بك
سيدي الرئيس طبعا انت مسؤوليتك تشمل ايضا
القائد العام انت القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه
وتحضر هذه القمه السنويا هذه القمه هذه
السنه تحديدا بعد مرور عام من غزو روسيا
لاوكرانيا ماذا تنتظر منها
نتوقع رؤيه واقعيه من خلال هذا المؤتمر
باتجاه الحرب القائمه في اوكرانيا تقد ان
المؤتمر الان يعقد قبيله اسبوع على مرور
السنه بالتناول كمال على انطلاق الحرب في
اوكرانيا واعتقد ان العالم عليه ان يدرك
ما تقوم به روسيا الان اتضح الامر بجلاء
روسيا دوله معتديه وعلينا ان نقوم برد فعل
مناسب اعتقد ان
هناك ضروره لكي تتخذ اوروبا وامريكا
والعالم ككل خطوه متقدمه والكل راى بان
روسيا دوله معتديه وعلينا ان نقوم بردت
فعل مناسبه الجزء من حلف النيتو والنيتو
وحلف دفاعي في العالم كما يعلم الجميع
ولدينا استراتيجيه تعتمد على
رد كل الاعتداءات وكل التهديدات نحن نعمل
على ردع روسيا
لاننا نعمل على الدفاع على انفسنا واعضاء
الحلف لكي تعرف روسيا بان دول النيتو
جاهزه للدفاع عن نفسها واي اعتداء على اي
دوله من النيتو فهو يعتبر هجوم على كافه
اعضاء الحلف واعتقد ان هذه سياسه السلام
علينا ان نجهز ما يكفي من المخدرات
العسكريه من اجل الدفع ودحر اي اعتداء
مستقبلي من قبل روسيا
السيد الرئيس اخذ منك الجمله الاخيره التي
ذكرتها الان تنتظرون خطوات متقدمه على
المستوى الدفاعي ماذا بالضبط
امدادات على مستوى مثلا الدبابات على
مستوى طائرات مقاتله على اي مستوى
علينا ان نوفر كل الحاجات الدفاعيه لو كان
كل ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا من اجل الدفاع عن
نفسها بنجاح
طبعا ينبغي ان يكون هناك تفاهم بين كل دول
النيتو ودول الحلفاء بخصوص ما هي المعدات
التي سيتم تسليمها لي اوكرانيا وايضا حجم
هذه الامتداد
كي تتمكن اوكرانيا من الدفع ودحر الهجمات
الروسيه
نعم ولكن هنا المشكله سيدي الرئيس المشكله
انه ليس هناك اجماع اوروبي حول هذه
المساله
وهذا دليل صمود روسي على مدار سنه كامله
وهي مساله موجوده يعني ليس هناك امكانيه
لاخراج روسيا من اوكرانيا كيف تفسر هذا
الامر
لكن سيتم الوصول الى الاجماع المنشود خطوه
خطوه هناك مجموعه من التصورات التي سيتم
وضعها الطاوله من اجل رسم الاجماع الذي
نامل اليه هذا الاجماع المهم جدا اوروبا
وامريكا وكندا وبقيه الدول ينبغي ان تسلم
اسلحه لاوكرانيا وينبغي ان تزيد من حجم
الامدادات لاوكرانيا كي تتمكن الاخيره من
الدفاع عن نفسها بنجاح
وتحر الاعتداءات الروسيه نحن نعلم ان
روسيا كانت تخطط لاحتلال اوكرانيا وهذا
طبعا فاشله وروسيا اخطات الحسابات روسيا
لم تاخذ مجموعه من العوامل بعين الاعتبار
اول شيء هو الشعب الاوكراني وارادته
للدفاع عن نفسه الشعب
الاوكراني يرفض ان يعيش تحت
الاحتلال الروسي الشيء الثاني روسيا
ساءت تقدير القوه وايضا التحالف الموجود
ما بين مختلف اعضاء الحلف وايضا اوكرانيا
نعم لكن السيد الرئيس انت رئيس اللاتينيه
هي من ضمن دول البلطيق هي من تقود ربما
يعني تيار
حتى لا نقول العداء ولكن
المعارضه لموسكو وصلتم مع روسيا الى حد
طرد السفراء الشهر الماضي في شهر يناير
الماضي كيف تتصورون العلاقه مع جار هو
روسيا ربما تتخوفون من ان يحدث لكم ما حدث
لاوكرانيا في المستقبل هل تخشون ذلك
[موسيقى]
نحن كما تعرفون جزء من النيتو وليس لدينا
هذا القلق نحن عضو في هذا الحلف الدفاعي
واعتقد ان كل الدول لا تشعر بهذا الحلق
لكن نحن لدينا دوما النظره واقعيه باتجاه
روسيا وكان الامر ذاته بالنسبه لبقيه
الدول المجتمه حتى البلطيق هذه
الرؤيه طبعا
باتت في
رهبتنا نراها في دول اخرى هذه النظره
الواقعيه لذلك هناك عمل متواصل مع كل
الحلفاء في الغربه وفي بقيه دول العالم
هناك بالتاكيد ضروره
للحفاظ على الامن والسلام في العالم
شكرا جزيلا لك رئيس لاتفيا كنت معنا في
هذه النافذه شكرا لك سيد الرئيس